video i'm going to show you how to load
some gene expression data
and then create some bar plots and
histograms to understand
what is in the data set so first of all
let's load the data i'm going to call it
df
and here i'm going to just use this
function read table
because it's a txt and i need to add
the name of the txt and i have here some
sample data with 1000 genes has some
nas in it so just we have a real world
situation to understand how the columns
are
organized they're separated by a tab so
here i have to write
sep and use this t
to show what it's separated by and then
i'm just going to
include a header because the names of
the samples
are included here in the name
and also i know
so i don't need this here and also
i know that my
row names are going to be useful as well
so i'm just going to say
row names equals one so that means that
the first row is actually
the row names okay let's make some space
here
so now i'm going to create some
variables or objects for example i will
store the names
under this variable names so i'll just
say in row
names df those are going to be my names
i'm also going to now manipulate the
data a little bit so for example
i want to omit all of the ma's so it
doesn't confuse
any of the downstream things that i do
so i'm going to just change df
and here i can use a function called n a
emit and that will just
reduce all of the nas then i will also
make a matrix out of this the problem
with some of the visualization
especially histograms and plots they do
not work with
data frames they need matrices so i'm
just going to make it into a matrix
and the way to do it is to do as matrix
in here at df and i'm going to
well first of all let's see what's
inside for example
you can say plot well bar plot sorry
or let's just do a box plot
df to see what's inside just click run
right here
let's see if everything works okay so
the code is successful
the problem is that all my data here is
down in the bottom
and there's a lot of outliers so there's
a lot of differences between these
so i would rather work with log scale
data
let's see how to do that actually very
simple so i'm going to create a new
object called df log and add here
log of df plus 1. now i'm doing plus one
because
uh logarithm of zero is going to be
infinity
and i will not be able to see what's in
my data
so let's try now what would that work
like
what would that look like all right
excellent so now everything is working
fine
except for i have these names down here
that are definitely cut off i don't see
all of them so that's simple i need to
do last equals two so last equals two
will help me convert them to uh
vertical alignment and
now i can see what's in my data now i'm
not going to really
need this anymore so i'm just going to
comment it out
okay now what if i want to
make a histogram of two samples
and compare their histograms
let's take for example
one of the samples so it's called sample
one and we'll call it
df log and this is going to be
let's take the first sample
so if i want to do a histogram
so hist histogram of sample one
that will look like this
okay so looks really nice
and here uh maybe i can give it a color
so for example i can recall equals red
now if i do that it's going to be red
colored shaded red here inside
i have frequency and sample one
maybe i want to
now do another sample so let's do sample
two
and we're going to say df log and
here we can take sample two
okay so histogram
for sample two and i make
wanna make it blue so
now i have two histograms one is red
another one is blue now they're fairly
similar uh
if i see all of my samples again
i'll see that there's actually two
distinct groups here
so this is example one and two they're
very similar but what if i take
one and one two three four five six so
one
versus six let's try that so what if i
do this
as six and
compare their histograms all right so
the histograms are now
somewhat different right so here's a
weird looking histogram
this one is a little bit more normal
neither one of them is actually normal
but let's try to combine them combining
them is actually very simple
i can just add here for example
add equals t
and that will combine those two
histograms together so it's a very
simple way of doing it but when i do
that i don't really
see one on top of the other because this
one is blocking that one
right so it's not a very good way of
doing it of course i can
switch them around right and so do first
this one and then that one so for
example
i can do this one first
and this one seconds
and maybe that's a little bit easier to
see
but again i don't achieve the desired
effect
so i have to think of something else so
to do that we need to add some alpha so
transparency to our colors
let's create color one and that color
one
is going to be rgb and i'm going to just
say
zero zero one and then alpha
0.5 so that's going to be
our color one
zero zero one zero 5 and color 2
is going to be rgb and here i'll do
1 0 0 0.5
so now instead of using blue and red let
me use
call 1 and
co 2. and let's see
what that looks like
all right so now i can see them
overlaying each other
and maybe i could switch them back to
being
the way i had it before
let's see if this looks better all right
so
there i have it probably not a good idea
so i'm just going to
undo this because it seems like my first
sample is bigger
but the problem is that these
bins are created automatically
and they're not very good
there's not high level of definition so
i can
actually add some more detail to this by
adding this
option breaks and let's add
200 okay so breaks
200 and let's see what that looks like
okay so now i have a very high
definition
histogram the problem is that i have
this very high peak in the very
beginning
and so that means that i have a lot of
low
frequency values and
a better way instead of a histogram to
actually
demonstrate what the two distributions
look like
is to use a density plot so let's create
a density plot
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to make the density calculation so
here i will add a density
for sample one
and d2 will be density
for sample two
now i can plot them so for example i can
plot d1
color equals red and let's see
what that looks like
all right so here is a nice density plot
right i like the curve let's try it with
d2
and let's do color blue
all right so that's what the blue looks
like how do we actually combine
the two together well
the way we do that is we combine them
instead of plot we'll just add a line to
the previous plot so here
i can do lines and i already have
d2 i'll do d1 and let's make this red
um and that's it this should work
let's see what it looks like all right
so there we go there we have the two
histograms together now would be nicer
to also add some uh more detail
so for example i can shade in the
area within these curves so the way to
do that
is to add a polygon and
i can do d2 and use
my color so which one did i use here
let's see so color one okay so let's do
color one
um sorry call one
and the other one
we will add maybe let's add border
well i don't think we actually need
border let's try that
all right so there it is you see i have
the blue inside here
uh it does come with so let's do
uh border equals
blue let's see what that looks like
all right nice blue color here and then
here we can add the same thing but for
d1
so d1 color 2
and this would be red
all right so here we have some nice
density plots easy to compare easy to
see
how they compare to each other okay so
we've got
a box plot we have a histogram
and we have a density plot that's it
all of this information is actually
available on code.omicslogic.com
and you will find here a number of
courses that you can use
and this was a preview of a course
in introduction to data science in r on
data visualization thank you and see you